[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
45 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hello.
MARK MANDEL: Hi Francesc.
How you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Pretty excited
about the interview
with, again, one of my
friends, Russell Smith
from Rainforest QA.
He's going to be telling
us about what they
do at Rainforest QA and how
they use BigQuery to power
all their analytics-- analytics.
MARK MANDEL: Analytics, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Analytics, basically.
MARK MANDEL:
Basically analytics.
No, it's actually really cool.
They have, again, CrossCloud.
It's an app running
on Heroku, and they
poured a lot of their
analytics over into BigQuery.
It's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I think that is
one of the ways people
start using Google Cloud
Platform very often.
It goes like oh,
BigQuery's cool.
MARK MANDEL: BigQuery's cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah-- so yeah.
So yeah, we're going to
be talking about that.
And then at the end
we're going to have
a question of the week
that comes-- actually we
have two questions of the week.
One is, OK, so I
want to do something
after I receive an email.
Not personally, but I want my--
MARK MANDEL: You might.
I don't know, you might.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Maybe.
I want my program to
react to emails, right?
How do I do that?
What is the best way?
And then we also have a question
about App Engine services would
be used to call App
Engines models from one
of our listeners, Stu--
I'm going to say Swartz,
but it's probably "Schwartz."
MARK MANDEL: "Shorts."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know.
I'm going to make it
German sound, "Schwartz."
MARK MANDEL: Schwartz.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But before that, we
have the cool things
of the week, as usual.
And the first one is the obvious
one, which is Kubernetes 1.4.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, super
excited about Kubernetes 1.4.
There's a bunch of
new things in here.
Just to pick out a couple of
my favorites, both of which
are in alpha, but I think
they're still really exciting.
The first is the Kube ADM tool.
This is really great.
So if you don't
run a GKE and you
want to create your own
Kubernetes clusters,
we now have a command
line tool that you
can spin up master
nodes and then
join other nodes to join it,
and makes it much easier.
Still in alpha, so
still worth kind
of playing with and
providing feedback.
But definitely the
right direction
for Kubernetes because
setting up a cluster before
was very, very difficult.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Yeah, there was that document
that I'm sure most of you
have heard about,
which was learning
Kubernetes the hard way.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah it was one
of Kelsey Hightower's Githubs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, which
is a very good document,
but it was also a very
good friction log.
Also because this
is really hard.
So yeah, the new
version is making
all of those things easier,
which is very necessary.
MARK MANDEL: And
also they're going
to have scheduled jobs,
which makes me very happy.
So if you want
something to happen
on a time based interval,
that's in alpha now as well.
I've been waiting
for that for ages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it is
actually very simple, but yeah.
Like I just assumed it was
always there, personally.
So it is very nice to see
that is finally there.
So yeah, if you
want to run-- I was
going to say a Cron job,
which is basically what it is.
You want to run a job like every
day at 8:00 AM, now you can.
MARK MANDEL: Well
looking at the syntax,
actually it used Crontab syntax.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it's
basically Cron jobs.
MARK MANDEL: It's
basically Cron.
It's pretty cool.
The other thing for cool
thing of the week, I just
wanted to make a call out to
some people in our community
and some of the stuff
they've been writing.
Oh, I'm going to mess this
up, Fernando Damian Lopez
wrote a really nice
little concise blog
post about just starting
up a Compute Engine
VM from App Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: I think this
is a very popular sort
of modus operandi
for a lot of people.
It's a very common pattern.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm assuming
he's using the REST API.
MARK MANDEL: He's
using the REST API.
He's got the source
code in Python
there, how to configure
the right permissions
on how to do stuff.
And it's just really
clean, concise,
and like yeah, if
you wanted to do it
from like a Cron job for
example or something like that.
It's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we have a
link to that in the show notes.
And there's actually
a fourth cool thing
of the week, which is a
cool thing of the day, which
is Google's 18th anniversary.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
just thought about that.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Happy birthday Google.
MARK MANDEL: Happy birthday.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
So I think it's time to go
talk to our friend Russell.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that then.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
very happy to welcome
Russell Smith to the podcast.
Hello, how are you doing?
RUSSELL SMITH: Good.
How you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very happy,
very excited about all
of the questions we're going to
be asking you today, especially
about the end, about BigQuery.
He just shared a
number of rows with me,
and I think it's very amazing.
But before we get into the
details of data and stuff
like that, why don't you tell
us a bit about who you are
and what you do?
RUSSELL SMITH: Cool.
So yeah, I'm Russell, CTO and
co-founder of Rainforest QA.
Basically CTO means a
lot of different things
to different people.
But for me it's, I run the
technical side of Rainforest.
So I'm responsible for the
direction and basically
that we're successful
technically.
So yeah, been going about four
or five years now, so 2012,
late 2011, 2012 kind of thing.
Moved over from the UK with
Fred, my co-founder, the CEO,
got into YC and started
working on Rainforest
shortly after that.
So yeah, that's a
brief history of Russ.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well that sounds
really interesting.
Why don't you tell us a little
bit about what Rainforest
QA-- what's the general gist?
What does the company do?
RUSSELL SMITH: Cool.
So Rainforest QA is a service.
So we give you a web interface
and APIs and command line tools
in order to do your QA.
So you can go in and
test in plain English.
So whether you're a
developer or a PM,
you can write basically
regression tests
for your web app.
Then you can trigger them
either using the interface
or using the API or put
it into your CI build,
which is one of the most
common ways of doing it.
So we enable you to do
human powered QA super,
super fast in a normal
continuous integration build.
So a lot of our
customers are using
it to speed up their
release process
by doing their QA in stuff
like CircleCI or Jenkins,
which is pretty cool.
The other thing is because
it's in plain English,
it's enabling other
people on the team
to write more maintainable tests
than would be with something
like general automation tools.
Which if you guys
have ever used them,
are generally pretty brittle.
Writing stuff in plain English,
whilst it has its nuances,
generally leads to a test that
is more reliable once you've
got it nailed down.
MARK MANDEL: So I can
write like a script
where I could be like, go
get a product that's green,
and then put it in
your shopping cart
and then go through
the checkout.
And then someone would
actually go ahead and do that.
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah,
the classic one
would be to ask them to sign
up and ask them to check
if the e-mail was received
or if they got a text
message to a number.
And all those kind of extra
tooling around e-mail checking,
third party auth, getting
phone numbers and stuff
is all handled by us and
automatic and pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So just to have an idea,
how does it actually work?
Like if I do this thing-- I was
like, I have my version, right?
RUSSELL SMITH: Classic question.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Like, how does
it-- like I have my version.
And I'm like, oh yeah, I
want to run some tests.
So I can give you
my script, which
is like, for instance, I'll
know, log into gcpodcast.com
and click on Download and
visit 45, for instance.
RUSSELL SMITH: That
would be a great test.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
RUSSELL SMITH: So OK, basically
we store all the stuff for you,
all your tests for you,
or you can store them
in plain text in your repo and
then just upload them to us
automatically.
Once you actually
hit our API and say,
hey, Rainforest,
run all these tests,
we do a couple of things.
One, we copy all those
tests and version them
so that if you ever change
your test in the future,
we know which ones we ran.
But then the next thing
is we start farming it out
to the workers we've got online.
So normally we have a
few thousand workers,
up to like 5000 workers
online at any one time.
And we're talking
about this earlier,
but we basically give out the
work in kind of a special way.
So we use Elixir projects.
This is one of our first
Elixir production apps
that connects to
a Chrome extension
that the testers download.
So we know which testers are
online when and when they
want to work.
So much like, say,
Uber, when you
want to do rides
as an Uber driver,
you just open up the app and
say hey, I want to do rides.
For our testers, they
just open up their browser
and then they just click
on the icon for Rainforest.
And it just turns it on.
And we know that they want work.
And then we can just
pipe the work to them.
So we can say,
hey, this person's
most qualified for the job
that you've just asked for.
We're going to give that to you.
So we can do that
very, very quickly.
So I guess stepping back a bit,
the traditional way of doing
this with a crowdsourced
based system,
so something like
MTurk or CrowdFlower
would be you do the
call to Rainforest.
Rainforest then does
a call to CrowdFlower,
say, and says hey, list
a job on the surface.
And then we list a job there.
Then the worker goes to the
page when they feel like it,
refreshes the page, sees
like a Craigslist style
listing of things to do, clicks
on one, maybe decides to do it,
and then does it.
So that process
took, I don't know,
three to seven minutes to
do, maybe, traditionally,
and then relied on workers
actually refreshing.
So we ended up building
notification services
on top of that.
But then we realized
the easier way
to do it is just to make them
install a Chrome extension,
or have them install
a Chrome extension.
So this is a much
more fluid way.
So after pressing the
button or using the API
or doing it in a build,
it's generally a few seconds
before we get the first
workers doing your work, which
is pretty crazy when you
realize how many humans that is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that is pretty amazing.
RUSSELL SMITH: We
accidentally DDoS-- not DDoS,
but we take people down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh really?
RUSSELL SMITH: Yes, so--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You're
testing for functionality,
but it's like oh yeah,
it doesn't scale.
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah.
So I mean, that's one
of the things we've
got to ship this quarter is
something to allow us to limit
the parallelism, because
I guess unlike, say,
if you are doing
testing traditionally
with Selenium style stuff,
a lot of the crowd-- crowd?
Cloud hosted providers
for that, maybe
you'll get 64 parallel
things at once.
We can do a couple of
thousand things in parallel.
So that tends to put a large
amount of load on your system,
if you're not used to it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So from an architectural
point of view,
how does Rainforest QA
distribute all of these flows?
Are these applications
that you're
testing running on the customer
side and you manage the--
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah.
Generally-- well in
fact 100% of cases,
the application is running--
the customer runs it.
And the main reason why is this.
Well, you guys are developers.
It's like so many different
ways of running something
and so many different ways of
having dependencies and getting
in the right state.
It's just totally
non-trivial to do to right,
to run somebody else's app.
So we let you run that.
And generally people deploy to
a staging or a QA environment
and then point Rainforest
at that, works pretty well.
If you're on Heroku,
you can actually
use this feature code review
apps, which is pretty bad ass.
If you do a pull request,
it will start an app
with that code and then you
can point Rainforest at that
as well.
I know you were talking about
doing that for Google, right,
for your App Engine stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, trying to
implement something like that.
And it is fun.
And I don't think
it is that hard.
So maybe we will be
able to share some news.
RUSSELL SMITH: What suspense.
MARK MANDEL: Well you could use
an App Engine version manually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So what I'm trying to do
is do it automatically.
It could be fun.
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah,
you could automate that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that is
about all the web integration
test.
Like all of that
is about the web.
What about mobile, mobile first?
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah, actually
there's a good point.
We launched-- I guess we've
been running mobile for,
I don't know, maybe
five or six months now
for a few customers,
maybe 10 customers.
And then last week we launched
a self-serve version of this
that anyone can sign
up to today, where
you prepay for
credits rather than
enter into a contract with us.
So yeah, we're powered
by Amazon's Device Farm.
I see you guys cringing.
You guys didn't do iOS fast
enough on your Firebase stuff,
so we had to go with them.
But they're awesome.
So they give us real
devices, like direct-- well,
I say direct, so they
give us real devices.
But the way they're designed
was for running automated tests.
So because we're
powered by humans,
we actually need to
give the device to them,
as in present it to the tester.
And it wasn't really
set up for that.
So we had to build
some pretty cool tech
to allow us to basically
transport the device
into the person's browser.
So the short version is we wrote
a VNC server and an SSH server
and some robust tunneling
magic that goes into the app
so we can inject into you app.
And then when your
app starts from there,
we can reverse
tunnel back into it
and take control
of the phone, which
is kind of awesome because it
turns out actually it works,
even though it
sounds totally crazy.
But it just means we can run
like 100, 200 devices at once
and give them out to
testers instantly.
So super low friction for you
as an end user, as a customer.
Also you, again, writing
tests in plain English,
so like low brittleness
of your test,
and also super easy
to get started.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So with
all of these testers and all
the testing devices that you
can be running at the same time,
I'm imagining that
you are generating
a pretty decent amount of data.
How do you how do
you handle that?
Do you create a-- do I get
an email saying passed?
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah--
well actually kind of.
So at a high level,
yeah, you'll get
a-- there's a bunch of
ways of notifying you.
But one of the
classic ones is email.
So you will get an e-mail
that just says passed.
But then it lists all
the tests that passed.
The interesting one is
when you get failures.
Like we'll send you the failure
and what browser or device
it failed on.
And then if you
click on the link,
you can go down into
seeing what the tester did,
whether that's through
screenshots or device
logs for iOS stuff.
Or for web stuff, we'll
give you half format,
which is-- I guess you
guys at Google people,
so it's a format I
think invented here
that Chrome exports from
the Network Debug panel.
So anyway, we'll give
you that same format,
which means you can use
some of the same tools
to introspect it and
figure out what's going on.
So you can get the
actual logs, because we
man in the middle
our own machines
to be able to track
all the requests that
go through-- all the
requests that the testers do.
Does that make sense?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
RUSSELL SMITH: As for where we
store that data, a bunch of it
is in Postgres.
Some of it now is going
into Google BigQuery.
And then a bunch of
it is stored on S3.
So the staticy stuff that
doesn't change is stored on S3.
MARK MANDEL: So you said
some of it goes to BigQuery.
Now you were sharing a very
large number with us earlier.
Is that really just
some of the data?
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah, that's
just some of the data.
So short version,
we are having--
we use Heroku like a lot.
Almost all of our
infrastructure's
on Heroku, apart from
the machines that provide
virtual machines to testers.
They're in a different place.
But Heroku has a super
little known feature
called log drains.
And log drains let
you pipe log output
from the app and all
the processes of the app
to anywhere you want.
So traditionally that
only support Syslog,
but they added an
undocumented, or I
think at the time
undocumented feature
where you could do
HTTP based transport.
So I spoke with you guys maybe
a year or two ago, a year ago
maybe, and figured
out, hey, I'm just
going to write a Go program
that uses the streaming
API for BigQuery and
just takes in all
the logs from our
entire infrastructure
and puts them into BigQuery.
So now the cool thing is we're
having a bunch of problems
with our logging provider, who
I'm guessing I should probably
not name because I don't
want any politics here.
But we are looking
for a good provider
one, that was fast
and searchable
and didn't have bad
retention and didn't cost us
an absolute fortune a year,
and then realized actually,
there aren't any.
By the way, we've since found
logdna.com, which I highly
recommend those guys.
They're cheap.
They do a good job.
They're not super lots
of bells and whistles,
but that's the
tradeoff with them.
They just do what you
need, which is search.
But anyway, we still
use BigQuery for this.
So Go program,
streaming API, takes
in all the logs from
our whole infrastructure
and just puts it
straight into a table.
It also doesn't extra
nice stuff for parsing out
the different fields and putting
them into the right columns.
But yeah, we've got about 25
billion log lines in BigQuery
now.
So it's kind of cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
Do you know how much
do you tend to ingest?
Can you share that with us,
like over a set time period?
RUSSELL SMITH: It's normally
a floor of like a 1,000
rows a seconds kind of thing.
And then it goes up
depending on traffic.
So that's normally our
baseline for Rainforest.
Maybe it's a bit lower at the
weekend, but during the week
it's about that.
So it's not super high
log wise, I guess.
It spikes though.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
mean, 1000 requests per second
is pretty decent, to be honest.
RUSSELL SMITH: So
triply, the program,
A, I've been meaning
to open source forever,
so I should probably
actually do.
But B, it runs on Heroku,
so it's like self.
It's kind of weird, Heroku
logs going to Heroku,
then going to you guys.
So yeah, super cool.
MARK MANDEL: And that's cool.
So once the data's
in BigQuery, what
are you actually
doing with it there?
RUSSELL SMITH:
Yeah, good question.
So we have a bunch
of standard queries
that we run to find some issues.
So we either run them
directly in your dashboard
or we use something
called Redash,
which I think you
actually recommended to me
like a while ago.
But Redash, for those
of you that don't know,
is kind of like open
source dashboarding system.
But it lets you run
queries on schedules
and it connects to
Postgres, Mongo, MySQL,
but also BigQuery and
Redshift, et cetera, et cetera,
etc. cetera.
So it's super cool for that.
So we use that.
So we have a bunch of
queries that run regularly
to find certain things
that we're looking forward,
do stats.
And it's super awesome because
it's cheap to run on you guys,
and it's also fast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So having
that amount of rows on BigQuery
I'm wondering,
how do you manage?
Do you actually have a
bunch of different tables?
It's just one humongous
table with billions of rows?
RUSSELL SMITH: LOL.
This is the noob mistake,
which I need to fix,
which I was reading the
docs about recently.
When I first started,
I didn't realize
that we should do named
date version tables.
Turns out at least
in the past that
was impossible to
fix without just
making a new set of tables,
which I didn't really
want to do.
So I think I read
the docs correctly
saying that I can
actually do that now
without taking it offline,
which looks kind of cool.
So anyway, I haven't
got around to it
because the cost is actually low
enough that I don't care, yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is nice.
RUSSELL SMITH: I'm kind
of attracted by the fact
that if the data is still
for a month or something,
it's like half the cost.
Is that correct?
There's some discount if
the data doesn't get added
to after a period of time.
Anyway, most of our [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
should check that out.
I'm not sure.
RUSSELL SMITH: No, I was digging
around the BigQuery docs,
so I'm pretty sure
that's correct.
But Google it yourself.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
so if a table is not
edited for 90 consecutive
days, the price of storage
that table automatically drops
by 50% to $0.01 per gigabyte--
RUSSELL SMITH: Which
is totally insane.
MARK MANDEL: $0.01 per
gigabyte per month.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh wow.
RUSSELL SMITH: It's insane.
And it's also awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is pretty awesome.
We learned BigQuery from him.
MARK MANDEL: That's
why we do this podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
not very good at this.
RUSSELL SMITH: So I need to
switch to partition tables
so that we can take
advantage of [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that way--
RUSSELL SMITH: No,
we have one table
with nearly 25 billion rows in.
And it's working,
which is kind of cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Out of curiosity,
how long does it take to execute
the most complex query you
have?
RUSSELL SMITH: So
normally we don't really
run queries over
the full data set
unless there's some
security thing that we're
trying to investigate.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is probably a good idea.
RUSSELL SMITH: And there's
this awesome thing in BigQuery
where you can scope not
by data in the table,
but by when that
data was inserted.
So almost all our
queries-- I can't
remember what it's called.
Anyway, almost all our
queries are done by that,
so depending on
what you're doing,
they're normally
either a day or weeks
worth of stuff, which I think
is actually the max for that.
But only on rare
circumstances do
we query all of the data ever.
So it's normally if we have
something that somebody's like,
oh, this thing happened
two months ago.
Can you help us?
I'm like, yeah, maybe we can.
Turns out-- so yeah,
we don't normally
query the whole data set.
So things are pretty quick,
like normally sub a minute.
I mean, we queried
earlier to find out
how many rows were
in the table today,
and that was the longest
where I've ever seen,
which was just over a minute.
And that's because it counted
every single thing ever,
which is kind of still
really cool, 68 seconds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 68
seconds to count--
RUSSELL SMITH: 25 billion rows.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 25 billion
rows, that is not bad.
RUSSELL SMITH: But I
can live with that.
MARK MANDEL: So you're talking
about your visualizations
and you're saying you were
using it to find certain issues
and things.
Can you talk a little bit
more, like what sort of issues
that you're looking for or
how you're using that in--
RUSSELL SMITH: In
the visualizations?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
RUSSELL SMITH: So I don't
know, we're looking at trends.
So we're also using
another awesome product
to do this, which
seems to actually
be the better way of doing it.
Short version, we're looking at
trends in memory usage or load.
Can we spot any trends
that are outliers
and then dig into
why this happened?
So we're actually
using a service
called Honeycomb.io, which
also, I think, is in beta,
but can super
recommend those guys.
Short version,
we're trying to find
like, hey, this bunch
of requests was slow.
Why was that?
And then for instance, we were
investigating the other day
and found one of
our diners, which
I guess Roku parlance for like
a machine running a process,
was using way more swap
than all the other machines
for no apparent reason.
So digging into that,
even finding that
was only possible using
BigQuery and Honeycomb.
MARK MANDEL: So
most of your data
really is about machine
analytics and stuff like that.
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah,
we haven't moved
to-- there's another thing
that we're working on,
which is to move
some of our data
or a lot of our most
important tables
from Postgres into BigQuery.
And the main reason we want to
do that is for doing analytics,
so finding out-- turns
out we have too much data
to be able to query the entire
thing at a reasonable speed
on Postgres.
So we've got, I
don't know, coming up
to 300 or 400 gigs of data,
which actually doesn't seem
like that much, but
turns out is enough it's
expensive to run at
a fast speed when
we're doing stupid queries.
So anyway, short
version, we're working
on a way of exporting that data
direct into BigQuery, which
will mean that we can do the
more insane queries faster,
which is going to be cool.
Maybe we'll open
source that as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, you should.
RUSSELL SMITH: Should open
source the first one as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
write a blog post you said.
RUSSELL SMITH: Good point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So now that you've
been using BigQuery for a
while, and as you were saying,
you had some noob mistakes,
like having just one
huge table for everything.
Do you have any other
piece of advice for people
that are starting to migrate?
They have like a huge
database relational,
and they're like oh,
should I move to BigQuery?
RUSSELL SMITH: Sure.
Basically the biggest
limitation when
I started doing it was-- well,
I guess I did read the docs,
but I just didn't bother
doing a bunch of stuff
because I wanted to get started.
But the biggest
thing I would say now
is make sure you read
the docs properly
and probably go with the
standard C core stuff, which
seems to be the new version.
I'm still on the older version.
The standard SQL
seems super awesome
because it removes one of the
major limitations of BigQuery,
which is updating
stuff, which now you
can treat it almost
like a proper-- eh,
almost like a proper database.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that is actually--
RUSSELL SMITH: I don't mean
that meanly by the way.
It's not like just
append only now.
You can actually update things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For
quite a long time, yeah,
BigQuery was only append only.
I mean, totally makes sense if
you're talking about something
to analyze logs.
RUSSELL SMITH: It totally
makes sense [INAUDIBLE]--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Modifying logs--
RUSSELL SMITH:
--use case for us,
but horrible use case for
the analytics stuff for us
because we need to
drop it every time we
want to update it
again, which I guess
is also possible, just-- yeah.
I would say definitely
look at the streaming API.
It's pretty awesome.
It also means
stuff's really fast.
There's a really good
Go library for it
that I found which I will
get put in the podcast notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we'll
put it on the show notes.
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah.
And then I guess the
only other thing-- what
do you want to do to wrap up?
The only other thing I was
going say was I'm in reInvent.
I'm speaking at
reInvent about MTurk.
So if anyone wants to
come say hi, do that.
I'll also be at the
CTO summit in November.
So if anyone wants to
say hi there, do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah, go find him and
ask him about BigQuery.
RUSSELL SMITH: Yeah, or Turk
or any crowdsourcing stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well thank you so much
for taking the time
to talk with us.
That's a very
interesting interview.
I will have a bunch of links
to all the different projects
that you have mentioned.
And hopefully we'll also
have links to the open source
versions of your [INAUDIBLE].
RUSSELL SMITH: I
just hired a VPN,
so I should actually have some
time to do this kind of stuff
now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well thank you.
RUSSELL SMITH: Cool.
Thanks guys.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
It was a pleasure and a joy to
have Russell Smith on with us
today.
I definitely appreciate
hearing about people
building interesting things,
especially I think CrossCloud.
I think that's
really interesting
to see how people are
doing that sort of stuff.
It was really good.
And the amount of data he's
processing, it's decent.
It's a decent amount.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is.
When he was walking away,
we had a quick chat.
And one of the things
that I was saying
was like, oh, so you
have 25 billion rows.
Are they very short rows?
He's like, oh no, they have
like tens or more fields.
I was like, oh wow, OK.
And some of the fields
have JSON inside.
So it was like decent
amount of data.
So I was like wow.
Yeah, very cool.
So yeah, looking forward
to all the open sourcing
of those tools.
I'm very excited
about that, especially
because they're written in Go.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, very good.
It'll make you very happy.
All right, cool.
So let's get into our question--
or apparently questions
of the week.
Yeah, you raised
the first one, which
I think is an interesting
one and got me very excited,
which is how to react to
email from Google Cloud.
So say I, I don't know--
this is always a fun one.
I'm going to get sent an
email by some third party,
[INAUDIBLE] for
example, and I want
to be able to automatically
do something about it
once I receive it.
How can I find out
when that email
comes to me so I can pass it
data and do stuff like that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
this actually comes
from a customer that
asked me this question.
And it was pretty
fun because they
were like, they need to
do something very complex
on Compute Engine.
And that very complex job needs
to be done every single time
that someone could
update a database that
was publicly available,
built by NASA actually.
And the impressive
thing is that the way
they're going to notify
people about there's
new data in the database
is by sending emails.
MARK MANDEL: Of course.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
So you had someone that was
receiving that e-mail that
then could go and run a script
that could start everything.
And I was like, I'm pretty
sure there's a better way
to do this.
And there's many
ways of doing it.
One of them could be run
your own web server--
run your own mail server.
MARK MANDEL: Let's not do that.
That doesn't sound like fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that is definitely not fun.
Then another thing you
could do is basically
use IMAP to connect from your
script that runs regularly,
like for instance using
Cron, and every hour
checks if there's new email.
If there's an email,
it starts doing stuff.
But then the problem is
how often do you check?
MARK MANDEL: You're
basically polling.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
you're polling all the time.
So it's not perfect.
And there's actually a
very, very easy solution,
which is just using App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: So App
Engine can receive email?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So you actually
get the same way--
you get a URL to host
your web server, which
is like yourappid.appspot.com.
You also get an email,
which is whatever you want,
at yourappid.appspotmail.com.
So if you send an email to
that address, what will happen
is that the email will be
sent as a POST HTTP request
to your application.
So now if your instance
is not running,
like your application is not
running because you don't how
any traffic-- which is probably
normal if you're only receiving
mail once a day--
what will happen
is that when you
receive that request,
your new instance will start,
and you will treat that,
and then you do
whatever you want.
And one of the
things that you can,
as we said at the
beginning of the podcast,
was that you can start a
new Compute Engine instance.
And then from there you
do whatever you need.
MARK MANDEL: I'm just
actually genuinely blown away
that App Engine
can receive email.
I didn't realize it could
do this, and it's so cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The best part
is that it has been there for,
like, ever.
It is really not new.
It is very simple.
And if you don't
know, it's there.
It is good.
MARK MANDEL: My mind
is literally blown.
It is literally blown.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
is a pretty fun thing to do.
And talking about
App Engine, we also
have a second question of the
week coming from our friend,
Stu Swartz, or "Schwartz."
Tell us how you pronounce it.
So it is about App
Engine services,
which for the people
that have been using
App Engine for a
while, you might have
known as App Engine modules.
And he's asking OK,
so when should I
use App Engine versus GKE?
And is this a scale
issue, and approach issue,
implementation issue?
And then the second
question, which
is more related to App
Engine services is, should I
have a bunch of services?
Should I have a
bunch of projects
and one service for a project?
The answer to the second
part of the question
is, well, have as many
services as you need.
Microservices are awesome.
MARK MANDEL: And when
you say services,
we're talking about modules.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Modules, yeah.
So you're going to have
basically a different app--
it's basically a different
App Engine application,
but they share the
same resources, right?
So if you want to make them
communicate through, like--
MARK MANDEL: REST.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--REST, you can.
But also you can use task
queues and all of these things.
And it's very easy to
communicate because they're
all in the same project.
When to use more than
one project-- normally,
I could reserve that to
different environments.
So you have like prod,
QA, stuff like that.
Then those are good
because that way
you're not sharing the data
store, which is probably
a good idea.
You should not give access
to the prod data just
to do the test, right?
So it is a good
place to separate.
But you should have all
your production services
in one single project,
much easier to handle.
And then about
the question, when
to use App Engine
versus GKE, maybe you
can give us a little bit
of background on that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So I had this as an
interesting question.
I'll hearken back for a
more detailed response
to our episode number two,
compute as a continuum,
where we go into much
nuanced detail about it.
But I feel like it's
really more a question
of how much flexibility
and control do you want?
App Engine standard
and App Engine flexible
will give you slightly
different versions
of that, whereas App
Engine standard, platform
as a service, we
dictate a lot of things
about how you do stuff.
But that gives you great scale,
which is really powerful.
Flex, we give you a few
more configuration options,
a few more bits and pieces.
So you can run pretty much
anything you want on it.
But now you can't scale to zero.
We don't spin up quite as fast.
So there's the tradeoff.
But if he want still
the sort of capability
such that things stay
up, if they fall over,
they come back, you
still want to be
able to deploy with
a rolling update,
things like that, GKE is
a great place for that.
But you now have
even more tweaks
and knobs that you
can pull around.
So you'll have a cluster
of machines in that case.
You pay for that
cluster machines.
You can auto scale
it to a degree.
But then you can do things
like resource management
or have jobs or now
schedule jobs as well once
that comes out of alpha.
But you have way more control.
And you can start--
you can say, maybe
I want to have stuff with a
whole bunch of memory in it,
which is way more than
I'd be able to get
on App Engine or something
like that, persistent volume
amounts.
If there's a state that I
want to go to put in places,
things that you
can't necessarily
do as easy on App Engine.
So it's probably really down
to what sort of application
you're building, and then
what sort of capabilities
you really want to be
able to have at hand.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
My rule of thumb is, if
it can run on App Engine,
it will run on App Engine,
because that way I can
forget about all of the devops.
And I just deploy
it, and I know it
will be running there forever.
And that makes me happy.
But if it's something that
I'm going to need to be like,
oh no, I have all
of these services
and there's
dependencies across them
and I want them to
be able to scale them
independently and scale
them independently
and all that stuff, then GKE
is probably the best place.
MARK MANDEL: Seems
pretty reasonable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well why don't you tell us a
little bit about what you're
going to be doing next weeks?
MARK MANDEL: So I've
got a lot of travel--
I say that with some
sadness-- during October.
But I'm doing some fun
events, so that's pretty cool.
So I will be at SIEGE in
Atlanta on the 8th of October.
That's going to be
fun, gaming conference.
After that I will be at
Connect.Tech on the 20th.
I'll be back in Atlanta
again on the 20th.
That's a general
webdev conference.
And then I'll be at
GamerCon, another game
conference on the 27th.
So I have a fair bit
of travel in October.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And yourself,
what are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So next
week I will be in New York.
And I'm going to be
running a workshop.
And you're all invited.
It's going to be on Wednesday
5, yeah, Wednesday 5, October 5,
so next Wednesday.
And yeah, it's about how to
build highly scalable web
applications with
Go on App Engine.
And it's going to be hosted
by Women Who Go in New York.
But everyone is
welcome, so we'll
have a link on the
show notes to that.
And then I'm also very excited
about something else, which
is not traveling, but kind of.
I'm going to be doing a
remote, a remote meet up.
And that will be on Monday
after that, so on October 10.
And it's going to
be kind of the same.
So it's a mini workshop.
It's how to build
a web application,
it says with Francesc.
It will be with Go actually.
But yeah, basically
it's going to be online
and you can ask all the
questions that you want.
So if you will be in
New York next week,
you're all invited to
come to that workshop.
But if not, the
Monday after that,
there will be something online.
And you can be there whatever
in the world you are.
And also it will be recorded
so that you can watch it later
if you want to.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
I should make mention that if
you are at any of the events
that we're going to be at, we do
have new GC Podcast" stickers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have stickers
and they're awesome, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And
they're awesome.
So if you happen to be where
we are and you want to come up
and say hi and get a
sticker, please do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And we also have T-shirts.
We don't travel around
with T-shirts all the time.
MARK MANDEL: No.
Sometimes I do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But what stickers--
MARK MANDEL: Stickers
are way easier to carry.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So come
find us and get stickers.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
All right, well
thank you very much
Francesc for joining
me yet again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
Mark, and talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]